[Musica]
la diversità è un valore
i team eterogenei performano meglio
innovano di più
le grandi squadre di calcio che vincono
i campionati sono squadre composte da
persone che arrivano da tutto il mondo
la loro diversità è un grandissimo
valore e questo è lo stesso racconto con
cui sono cresciuta Anch'io sono figlia
di una coppia mista mia mamma Annamaria
italiana e Cattolica mio papà Iaia
ivoriano ai musulmano
mia mamma ha un fratello e una sorella
e mio nonno Carlo Maria è stato
sindacalista in precedenza partigiano
partito quando il mio bisnonno Fu
arrestato e deportato e ammazzato in un
campo di concentramento in quanto
antifascista mio papà Iaia ha 13 tra
fratelli e sorelle il mio nonno mamadu
aveva tre mogli
vi racconto questo aneddoto Giusto per
farvi respirare un po' della grande
diversità culturale che ha vietato la
mia casa e la mia famiglia anche ai
figli di coppie miste dicono che la loro
diversità è un grandissimo valore
connettono più mondi connettono più
lingue mettono in contatto infatti
guardando le mie foto da piccola mi
sembra di non assomigliare a nessuno dei
due di essere il mix perfetto tra tratti
somatici e colore della pelle
avevo quattro anni quando questa
affermazione la diversità è un valore ha
iniziato a risuonare nella mia testa
come una domanda
la diversità è davvero un valore quando
avevo 4 anni I miei genitori si sono
separati I motivi della separazione sono
stati moltissimi Ma il primo posto senza
dubbio le differenze culturali tutte le
sere a cena si discuteva su quanto
riempire il bicchiere d'acqua mia madre
è abituata a riempire il bicchiere
d'acqua a metà Mio padre è abituato a
riempirlo fino all'orlo prima a tutti i
commensali a tavola e sono alla fine a
se stesso
discussioni infinite su quanto riempire
quel bicchiere d'acqua solo anni dopo
emerso che quella di mia mamma era
un'abitudine culturale e che ha la
stessa che ho acquisito anch'io se
qualcuno oggi mi chiedesse perché
riempio il bicchiere d'acqua a metà non
saprei rispondere l'abitudine di mio
padre raccontava anche in questo caso
della sua storia della sua famiglia
l'acqua per lui è il bene più prezioso A
volte sostituiva anche il cibo riempie
il bicchiere d'acqua con commensale a
tavola e il gesto di fede e di amore più
grande che si potesse immaginare
per arrivare poi alle medicine mia madre
con i farmaci da banco mio padre con le
candele gli unguenti curativi inviati
Dalla Costa d'Avorio e per arrivare poi
alla religione
Mia mamma ha tutte le domeniche in
chiesa mio papà cinque volte al giorno
tassativamente prendeva il suo tappetino
verde nero lo portava nella mia camera
lo posizionava nella direzione di La
Mecca iniziava a pregare la storia della
mia famiglia è una storia di
multiculturalità ma è anche una storia
di fallimento di due diversità che ha
funzionato insieme non ce l'hanno fatta
Ed è stato questo il momento in cui un
po' inconsapevolmente ho capito cosa
avrei voluto fare da grande cercare di
capire perché tra i miei non avesse
funzionato cercare di rispondere a
questa domanda capire cosa succede
quando persone diverse culture diverse
entrano in contatto tra loro
negli anni ho iniziato a costruire le
prime risposte frequentando
dall'ambiente accademico alle
associazioni alle aziende ma soprattutto
ha scoperto tre cose che nessuno mi
aveva mai detto e che non ci dicono
sulla diversità Partiamo dalla prima
25 Aprile banchina metro rossa Duomo
Milano
banchina pienissima sto aspettando la
metro
a un certo punto sento un ticchettio
sulla spalla mi giro vedo un ragazzo
nero
faccio un passo indietro e dico non ho
non ho niente
un secondo dopo realizzo e mi sento
morire dentro proprio io con la mia
storia
esperta di diversità inclusione mi sono
interrogata su questo episodio molto a
lungo come mai quel ragazzo tra tutte le
persone sulla banchina si era avvicinato
proprio a me e se fosse stato bianco
avrei reagito allo stesso modo
la prima scoperta è che siamo fatti per
costruire con che ci somiglia
le neuroscienze La psicologia sociale ci
dicono che siamo più attratti da persone
che sono più simili a noi e invece più
respingenti a volte spaventati da
persone che da noi sono molto diverse
ascoltandomi Però potremmo dire parliamo
di diversità similitudini quel ragazzo
era nero quindi era simile a me E qui la
seconda scoperta
vi racconto stiamo tutti uguali a una
grandissima bugia
ognuno di noi porta con sé così tante
diversità che non è possibile
catalogarle
è vero Io sono nera proprio come quel
ragazzo ma sono anche figlia della mia
storia della mia famiglia Sono figlia
della città in cui sono nata e cresciuta
Roma e del mio accento Sono figlia delle
mie paure delle mie sofferenze delle mie
gioie e delle mie soddisfazioni
[Musica]
sono moglie non sono madre non sono
sorella Sono figlia sono amica
alcune di queste diversità mi hanno
messo mi metteranno nella mia vita nella
condizione di ottenere delle opportunità
alcune di queste diversità mi hanno
messe mi metteranno nella mia vita nella
condizione di perdere delle opportunità
e poi arriviamo alla terza scoperta che
è stata forse per me la più importante
era domenica avevo sette anni I miei
erano separati ma il fine settimana
passavamo tantissimo tempo insieme mia
mamma come al solito in chiesa mio papà
prendeva il suo tappetino e iniziava a
pregare io mi mettevo al suo fianco un
po' per imitarne i gesti le parole come
se fosse un gioco ma anche nella
consapevolezza che si trattasse di
rituale di Fede molto profondo quel
giorno a cena condivisi con i miei un
dubbio Come mai non preghiamo tutti
insieme
ci fu un momento di silenzio i miei si
guardarono negli occhi mi chiesero un
attimo di tempo per rispondere a questa
domanda se qualcuno in quel momento mi
avesse chiesto la diversità è un valore
avrei risposto che no la diversità non
basta aumentare la fatica la complessità
l'impegno il tempo richiede conflitto la
mia casa era piena di diversità Ma
questo diversità abitavano letteralmente
due stanze diverse che non si
incontravano mai il giorno dopo i miei
tornarono da me con una risposta perché
una volta a settimana non preghiamo
tutti insieme La domenica mano nella
mano sul divano 10 minuti a occhi chiusi
ricordo benissimo la prima domenica di
preghiera tutti insieme eravamo sul
nostro divano di vimini quello che
vedete in foto io ero al centro mia
mamma a destra mio papà a sinistra ma
non è la mano ha occhi chiusi non so
dire in quel momento A che cosa
fregassero in che lingua io mi muovevo
tra Ave Maria assure pregava un Dio che
in quel momento per me non aveva un nome
Se ripenso a quel momento lo ricordo con
grandissimo emozione
sento dentro di me famiglia
Gioia felicità
amore
sento dentro di me la gratitudine per il
tempo che loro si sono presi per
costruire una risposta che parlasse di
tutti e tre quello per me è stato il
giorno più speciale di tutti perché è
stato probabilmente il primo giorno in
cui ho conosciuto l'inclusione
l'inclusione unisce cambia il mondo
genera innovazione ci mette nelle
condizioni di fare quelle cose che non
abbiamo mai fatto di provare quelle cose
che non abbiamo mai provato di guardare
il mondo attraverso occhiali che non
abbiamo mai indossato l'inclusione si
muove tutte quelle volte in cui siamo
disposti ad ascoltare senza giudizio
quando esprimiamo le nostre idee il
nostro punto di vista anche se non è
concorde con il punto di vista di chi ci
sta ascoltando
quando ci sentiamo libere e liberi di
valorizzare le nostre unicità anche
quelle che facciamo più fatica a
raccontare anche a noi stessi
quel giorno ho scoperto l'inclusione ma
ne ho compresa anche la sua complessità
il tempo e lo spazio richiesto dai miei
per lasciar da parte un po' del loro
rituale costruire qualcosa di nuovo che
raccontasse di tutti e tre se qualcuno
mi chiedesse oggi di rinunciare ad un
pezzo del mio rituale di Fede per fare
un po' di questo a qualcun altro sarò
onesta non so se sarà in grado di
rispondere di sì alla domanda la
diversità è un valore oggi risponderei
che sì è un valore ma una condizione
allo spazio a cui siamo disposti a
rinunciare per fare un po' di spazio a
qualcun altro anche se questo qualcun
altro è ospite a casa nostra al
privilegio a cui siamo disposti a
rinunciare per dare un po' di privilegio
a qualcun altro il privilegio è
quell'elemento innato acquisito che ci
mette una condizione di potere lasciarlo
andare non è per niente semplice quello
che non ci dicono sulla diversità è che
è terribilmente complessa e da sola non
basta quello che non ci dicono sulla
diversità e che l'inclusione Non è
aggiungere un posto a tavola ma fare il
proprio posto un po' più piccolo perché
la verità è che i posti a tavola i posti
del potere dell'economia della politica
delle relazioni dell'identità sono
limitati quello che non ci dicono se la
diversità è che l'inclusione Non è una
condizione è una scelta quello che non
ci dicono sulla diversità e che
l'inclusione Non è inglobare qualcuno
all'interno del proprio spazio ma
mettersi nella condizione di fare un
passo un po' più là e lasciar andare un
po'
stato proprio privilegio quello che non
ci dicono sulla diversità è che
l'inclusione È tutto un equilibrio tra
cosa do e cosa prendo negli ultimi anni
la grande domanda che mi ha accompagnato
fin qui ha lasciato il posto nonno Nova
domanda che porto con me tutti i giorni
su cui cerco di interrogarmi in modo
autentico e su cui interrogo le persone
che incontro lungo la mia strada le
aziende che vogliono rendere le loro
organizzazioni più inclusive o i manager
che vogliono rendere i loro Team più
inclusivi tutte quelle persone che fanno
fatica a relazionarsi con la diversità
per me è una domanda speciale e sincera
e per questo oggi vorrei regalarla anche
a voi
e tu
a cosa sei disposto a rinunciare per
fare un po' di spazio a qualcun altro
Grazie
[Musica]